you just came out with your first album
in four years yeah for nine years
good for you congratulations we you give
but I just just just it's not the album
a single came out single came out a song
called walk on water just came out it is
our first music in four and a half years
the album will be coming out pretty soon
alright so this was just the sort of the
the sampler taste when you give a live
show you've been known to really go all
out we have footage of you making an
entrance in one of your concerts on a
zipline yeah and I just I wanted to show
that because I was really impressed with
this this he if I can't tell from a
distance I can't tell it through scared
if that's happening against you have me
against your will
now that it looked like you were doing
what I would do if I was on a zip line
no I was hamming it up a bit yeah I
should do if you're on a zip line over a
hundred thousand people in Rio yeah
but the zip line was actually set up
there and set up all day long and I and
I just ran out and jumped on it oh
that's cool is it it wasn't just for my
show but it was really fun
you